what it it starts with for example is
good broad-based education it starts
with education educated people are are
more valuable but and it's and there's
two types of Education there's education
of like what you know and what skills
you develop but there's also learning
civility learning how to behave with
each other how do you behave with others
to make a productive society and so
related to that as we think about that
think about parenting think about the
importance really what what you what I
had was just going back to the basics uh
what I had was parents who love me and
were good guidance I had a public I went
to a public education and it was public
school and it was a good public school
and I came out to a world of equal
opportunity in which there was an
opportunity to make decisions and make
things happen and then and live the
American dream and really those are the
most important fundamentals like if you
can get good guidance in their in your
life and you can have good education and
you have a system that provides you good
and equal opportunity I mean that's
basically it